So why is it so so angry?
Because you don't care! You don't look, you don't even pay a single finger, you don't even do the bare bare minimum, like even below the bare minimum.
And then you come and tell me about "oh you should do this"
I'm telling you that your money paid for QuickBooks 100% and you now...
No, and then I was like "oh well I didn't know about that because it's connected to my mom's personal account"
And then you started preaching about fucking "oh I should do this"
I am trying to help you!
No you're not! No you're fucking not because if you actually were, you know why?
It took you like how many arguments did it take for me to convince you to just make that one call to ask around for the Yuzu location?
Like if you actually wanted to help out, you would actually listen and do that.
Why should you do it? That's the word!
Because I don't know! That's the value that you can... I don't know!
You keep asking Noah how can you help and then we tell you exactly the ways that you can help and then you don't do it!
Ricky, Ricky, regarding the location...
No, no that's just an example, one example out of many.
Okay, regarding the accounting and regarding this accounting...
Again, these are just examples...
Dude, look, there's nothing... there's nothing that will change my position, Ricky!
Exactly! That's exactly the fucking point!
There's nothing, there's nothing that is... exactly that's the fucking issue!
If you continue...
You have no open mind!
If you continue discussing, you think that I am going to change, forget it!
I prefer to grasp, use to serve and close me!
So how is that not hatred? Oh, and then you call me "Oh, I'm a hatred!"
That's what you are acting to! That's what you are producing!
No, that's what you're...
You think that I am bitching me, that I am not doing this...
Okay, I tried to do what I could!
If you don't... if you want to know me to do more...
Even Taiki told you the same thing!
I cannot, no, I don't bring Taiki!
I'm sorry, I cannot do anymore!
Put video! Put it in that way!
That's bullshit!
Bullshit! Bullshit for you!
But not in the reality!
Bullshit for everybody else except for your little fucking fantasy!
Yeah, okay!
My, my fantasy!
Let me eat my fantasy!
I don't mind!
I know you don't mind!
But it affects everybody else!
I mean what...
It affects everybody else!
You are the emperor that is going to ruin my life!
What do you think?
Oh, okay!
Do you want me to stay...
To start telling you that you are...
What do you say?
To me?
I want you...
No, no, I'm not going to go to your level, Ricky!
Period!
My level?
Yes!
You think that I am a Christian!